there's a Neil Diamond novel called
american gods in which that the deities
are these super human beings that
gradually emerged from the imagination
of society and they feed on human belief
and gradually they acquire the power to
influence events in the real world so
today I want to talk to you about an
idea from evolutionary biology that
something a bit like this might be going
on in our everyday lives I'm not talking
about a supernatural process I'm talking
about something that's commonplace even
ubiquitous in evolution it's just not
very easy to recognize when it's
happening to you so to clarify this
let's talk about what it means to be an
individual we tend to think of ourselves
as fundamentally discrete unique well
defined beings I mean the idea of
individual rights and responsibilities
is pretty much the foundation of Western
democracy but is that perception
accurate when you look closely there are
all sorts of problems with the idea we
share thoughts ideas and beliefs with
other people is the future you still you
if we replace part of your brain are you
still you what if we replace your whole
brain what if we make copies of you when
we're confronted with the sort of
confusion we tend to resort to a sort of
biological intuition a common-sense
definition of an individual or something
with a unique body and a unique genome
but it turns out this just leads to more
problems so finally we can move to
talking about an individual from a
purely evolutionary Darwinian
perspective in which case we define it
as an entity that's bound together by
some sort of shared fitness and at last
we have a definition that's consistent
in the sense that we can apply it to
genes and groups of cells and maybe even
at higher levels but it also creates one
big caveat which is that we can no
longer treat individuality as a binary
variable we have to think of it as a
something that emerges by degrees and
can be found in all sorts of partially
formed states in nature so for example
you probably think of a dandelion as
this itty bitty plant that's about six
inches across but dandelions have a
special way of reproducing their flowers
make seeds which are genetically
identical to the parent plant and those
seeds get distributed all around the
parent so when you look at a field of
dandelions you're actually looking at a
field of clones or in evolutionary terms
you're looking at a single individual in
effect a dandelion field is actually one
very large tree that just doesn't happen
to have a root system or a trunk it's
the same with animals there are many
species like corals jellyfish and aphids
that alternate between clonal sexual and
even colonial forms where the same
genome can be located in many bodies and
many bodies can unify into one and then
fragment again this for instance is a
diagram of the coral life cycle and
without going into details you can see
that it's actually really hard to define
where an individual begins or ends at
the same time different genomes can
become inextricably entwined the most
dramatic example of this is
endosymbiosis where cells incorporate
other cells and ultimately assimilate
them so that they can no longer survive
or reproduce outside the other cell this
is how plants turn sunlight into sugar
and also how plants and animals turn
sugar into energy so it's an absolutely
fundamental process to most of what we
see going on around us in life there are
also much more dynamic interactions and
relationships between genomes for
instance your gut fauna comprised ninety
percent of the cells in your body and
have ninety-nine percent of the genes
how does your relationship with them
work are they part of you or part of
something else
so from all this complexity how can we
extract some sense of identity the
traditional approach in evolutionary
biology is kin selection where we use
this relationship called Hamilton's rule
our be greater than C so if you're if
you're related if the product of our
relatedness and the benefit to you
exceeds the cost to me then I ought to
behave altruistically toward you in fact
us this isn't actually so simple
relatedness is relative to the rest of
the population and it can be offset by
competition often the people you have
most opportunity to help are also the
people that you're competing with most
directly and really you should also be
helping things that help you regardless
of whether you're how related they are
to you so an approach that deals with
this complexity of clonal evolution and
symbiosis is multilevel selection theory
that is the units of selection genes
cells or organisms tend to aggregate in
groups and reproduce as a unit this in
turn creates higher level units which
can be under selection in different
directions it's this continuous
interleaving of competition and
cooperation at different scales in
evolution often these groups will
themselves consist of related units like
bacterial colonies or the cells in most
of your organs but they can also be
unrelated like your gut fauna so this is
in a sense a much broader approach than
kin selection how important it is
generally is still very controversial
within biology but I am going to talk
about some research that suggests it may
be very important for human biology in
particular so how do these collective
entities emerge that consists of animals
with different genomes in most case we
think it starts with kin selection the
often one of the best things that you
can do evolutionarily is to help your
offspring like that sparrow in the
corner but sometimes you might not have
the opportunity to breed for yourself
for instance if you don't have the
resources to build your own home so in
this case the best way to improve your
fitness might be to stay home delay
breeding and instead help your parents
to raise your siblings so when housing
is too expensive or no jobs are
available you don't try to get married
in fact you don't mature at all you live
in your parents basement indefinitely
but what if there are never enough
resources to breed independently in that
case you might as well just dedicate
your whole physiology to helping your
parents and when this happens
consistently enough you can get the
emergence of a superorganism where many
of the offspring remains sterile for
their entire lives now this is actually
a fantastic situation from an
evolutionary perspective because it
means that you can create division of
labor you can have some individuals who
specialize in foraging others who build
air-conditioned fortresses or work on
farms and others who form armies to
defend your cities and attack your
rivals it's an extraordinarily
successful way of life so much so that
it can be maintained even if the
original relatedness that started it is
lost this is something that we see in
ant colonies where you sociality seems
to start with a monogamous Queen which
means that everyone in the nest is
closely related but later on in
evolution the Queen's might have
multiple mates or they might even be
multiple queens in the same colony and
the best example of this is the
Argentine ant which has created
cooperative super colonies across
several continents but when you have
this decline in relatedness you also
have a an incentive to cheat for example
sometimes
worker ants will try to lay eggs of
their own to be raised in shared
nurseries and these cheating queens will
grow up to start new colonies that are
more closely related to the to the
sheathing worker so evolutionarily
speaking this is a profitable cheating
strategy the same sort of thing happens
within our own bodies at the cellular
level we have a division of labor among
cell lineages that form different organs
virtually all of these lineages are
doomed after about 50 divisions they
will lose the ability to divide but as
they're dividing they can also evolve by
natural selection especially through
changes to epigenetic markers which
switch different parts of the genome on
and off so cell lineages in your body
are under selection to survive and breed
faster than other cell lineages if they
succeed you'll get cancer mostly of
course these cancers are themselves
doomed because they kill their hosts but
there have been a couple of cases where
cancers managed to escape and survive in
the outside world one is Tasmanian
devils with an infectious cancer has
wiped out about seventy percent of the
population since the early 1990s another
example is a venereal cancer of dogs
that survive for about 11,000 years
whilst your average dog is lucky to make
it to 15 so it's not the most dignified
form of immortality you can imagine but
it's something so maintaining
cooperation is an eternal problem for
collectives even when they are basically
genetically identical their selection to
rebel and the problem becomes worse if
we're talking about diverse individuals
to begin with it seems that one of the
universal solutions to this is policing
we punish cheats for example worker ants
will often brutally attack other workers
when they catch them trying to lay eggs
and they will tear their limbs off this
punishment creates another problem if
you have police who have special powers
they can be corrupted and in fact in
some ant species the the individuals who
cheat are consistently the police
officers so one way to one way you can
escape this corruption problem by a game
theory models is how we know about this
stuff one way you can escape this is if
everyone evolved to be a police officer
and in that case the cheats get caught
very quickly and cheating disappears so
this seems to be the solution that honey
bees and perhaps ourselves have have hit
upon and perhaps it's something that
happens in human society as well so at
last we can touch start to talk about
human cooperation and social behavior at
some point in our evolutionary history
we went through a very dramatic social
transition ape societies are generally
hierarchical but human hunter gatherers
are consistently quite egalitarian they
share food they make decisions
collectively and they they really don't
like arrogant and boastful people so how
did we make this transition from from
the very aggressive linear hierarchies
of apes to human egalitarianism we don't
really know but many researchers think
it's an adaptation to competition
between tribes so groups of male chimps
will sometimes get together to raid
other groups in a sort of simple warfare
and the argument is that in human
evolutionary history the smarter
individuals were better at social
manipulation promoting alliance
formation and their collective Fitness
non-hierarchical alliances are
inherently less wasteful fall for the
group because there's no squabbling over
who comes first so when tribes compete
the ones with large ilagay egalitarian
coalition's
and strong cooperative social norms will
tend to win looking at human
psychological studies we can see a lot
of stuff that seems to fit with this
view of humans as a species that's
adapted to group level competition and
social coordination we fit in very
willingly with the social norms and
expectations of a group regardless of
our personal morality in the stanford
prison experiment that was conducted
right here for example students were
given the rolls of prisoners and guards
which they played with such enthusiasm
that the experiment had to be called off
after six days because the prisoners
were being violently abused I don't
think so I don't think any ethics
committees would it could be but I think
we have some evidence from other other
areas that that we can get humans to
behave similarly one for instance was
the the Milgram experiments where they
they got one student to play a victim
and another student to give them
electric shocks and the outcome was but
most most of the arm the ones giving the
shocks would do it until it appeared
that the the victim was dead unconscious
yes well though I think they had a big
red X on the dial or something so what
it was very ambiguous but it definitely
sinister so know that there are
countless studies that show people tend
to favor their own group above other
groups there was one study where people
were just randomly given small colored
tokens and then they would though that
they were told that this was random and
there was also told that it would have
absolutely no impact on anything and
then then they immediately started to
treat the
the people who had the same color token
much more favorably than anyone else
experiment the difference I don't know
about the experimenters I don't think
they have no concern is even some
evidence that this in-group favoritism
is driven by um oxytocin which is the
the famous hormone of love and trust
apparently it only increases love and
trust within groups and it actually
makes you more likely to discriminate
against other groups and of course
another issue is another sort of
adaptation to living in groups is our
propensity to cheat and we it seems we
have dedicated cognitive architecture to
deal with this possibility we like to
punish cheats and we like it when other
people punished sheets we're better at
reasoning when we frame a logic problem
in terms of how can I detect this cheat
and we're also corruptible when you make
people feel empowered they become more
punitive towards others who violate
social norms and at the same time less
likely to adhere to those norms
themselves so all in all it seems we
have a ton of evolved cognitive
architecture to help us live in groups
and subtly manipulate things to our own
advantage within these groups now in
modern-day life we've seen human
collectives of emerged that can survive
far beyond the lifetime of an individual
and they sex that they satisfy the
general requirements for being under
natural selection this was first noticed
by milton friedman in reference to firms
new firms arise they copy one another's
successful business strategies some grow
and spread and others go out of business
as they compete so this is this is one
of the foundations of the field of
evolutionary economics
and if you believe in the free market
this could be a very beautiful thing
because firms are supposed to be
evolving just to make stuff that people
are willing to buy and people are of
course completely rational free agents
unfortunately the real picture is not so
simple the evolutionary argument doesn't
apply just affirms it also applies to
all human organizations whether they're
government-driven religious or nonprofit
they all compete for survival and
proliferation and they all adopt
successful strategies that they've seen
in others and this competition isn't
necessarily about satisfying a perfectly
rational consumer it's about exploiting
human nature human nature comes with all
this pre evolved cognitive architecture
for group life a host of cognitive
biases a tendency to anthropomorphism a
craving for social status loyalty and
aggression towards anyone we perceive to
be violating social norms that's a
fantastic pile of material for selection
to work with on the level all on the
level of collectives so one of the
things that organizations can do is they
can accrue power by power I mean both
money and less tangible forms of
influence the sort of influence that
means your interests are a principal
concern when world shaping decisions get
made we tend to have a slightly naive
view of power within an organization as
something like this pyramid or Christmas
tree most people don't have much but
there's a hierarchy of managers and
bosses who have some sort of influence
the powerful people and then if you're
really lucky you get to be the star at
the top of the Christmas tree the king
and the King does whatever he wants in
real life Kings are not free agents
their choices are extremely constrained
they spend most of their time trying to
maintain and expand the systems that got
them into power in the first place so in
a sense the whole organ that
organization is acting as a
self-perpetuating cycle under natural
selection and power
is occurring within the cycle away from
the individuals who comprise it
including the Kings so one of the most
famous biologists of our time yo Wilson
has argued that humans assoc allottee of
this sort means we should actually
consider ourselves to be super organisms
most biologists don't really agree with
this because super organisms usually
consist of a small number of parents and
a lot of several workers which is not
how we roll however I think there is a
strong argument that human collectives
need to be considered as operating as
evolutionary entities in their own right
which makes them a sort of biological
individual and this selection is in some
ways perhaps more powerful than the
selection that drives the formation of
normal biological super organisms
because super organisms usually
reproduce very slowly compared with the
the organisms that comprise them which
place is very strong limits on the pace
of their evolution because humans aren't
tied for a lifetime to one collective
our collectives can evolve extremely
rapidly more rapidly than we can
collectives can achieve amazing things
precisely because they concentrate power
so effectively at a level beyond the
individual no human could ever create
the Pyramids of Giza but rapidly
evolving collectives that accrue power
are not necessarily always acting in our
best interests what happens when there's
a conflict of interest between human
individuals and the collective's that
comprise them it seems human interests
often get overridden and whilst we might
like to demonize individuals for
justifying the selfishness of the
collective's they work for we tend to
forget that the collective itself is
explicitly set up and constantly
evolving to favor such selfishness
I'm guessing your final quote there was
it last week or two not something you
agent yes the the history of the
cigarette is a vivid illustration of how
collective interests aren't necessarily
good for Humanity as early as the 1940s
a medical consensus had emerged that
smoking causes lung cancer the tobacco
industry worked together they recognize
this threat in the early 1950s and they
figured out numerous ways to undermine
this consensus they developed public
relations tactics to engineer consent
whilst casting doubt on research
findings they set up their own research
funding bodies under the guise of taking
responsibility for their product and
then redirected the research to avoid
any problematic findings and at the same
time they developed a huge network of
media political and scientific contacts
all the strategic work paid off greatly
such that cigarette sales rose
substantially over the following decade
today cigarettes still killed one and a
half million people every year there's
no single human individual responsible
for this disaster it's the product of a
collective interest that quite directly
opposes human well-being and has the
power to motivate numerous individuals
to each play a small part in maintaining
it I'm not sure the camps is actually
profit directly but you never know maybe
one of them will escape so why am I
telling a bunch of computer scientists
about this it's because of how machine
learning might play into this sort of
dystopian collective dynamic first off
big data gives collectives unprecedented
opportunities to understand and
manipulate humans companies that deliver
news feeds are in a position of
extraordinary power it's not just about
controlling the information that you see
but about externally regulating
your emotions and choices for instance
there was a rather disturbing study
recently where Facebook demonstrated
that they could directly change people's
moods just by manipulating what they saw
in their feed the proportion of positive
content you can foster loyalties and
promote social norms that benefit the
collective using tokens and punishments
you can reward people with status
symbols that don't actually enhance
their well-being and you can predict
everything from stock market prices to
epidemics using social media chatter
wealthy or in profit lastly you can set
up your system so that the system never
actually gets the blame for any problems
and establishment and maintain
relationships with other collectives
that buffer you against human influence
so all of these manipulations contribute
to diverting power from individuals to
collectives here's a purely hypothetical
example of how data analysis equals
power there were two studies from
Facebook in one case Facebook report
reported that they could quite reliably
predict people's political affiliations
from their likes this isn't surprising
at all after all lots of things
correlate with likes very nicely a while
later they reported that they could
increase voter turnout by showing people
whether their friends had voted and this
was hailed as a wonderful thing for
democracy after all who doesn't want to
increase voter turnout but when you take
when you take these two results together
obviously it would be quite trivial to
use this information to manipulate
election outcomes by showing the vote
about a button to people who you want to
vote and what's worse is that the feed
algorithm is completely opaque we have
absolutely no way of knowing if any
company is doing anything like this
a second disturbing aspect of this is
that machine learning is becoming
ubiquitous and outperforming humans in
both data analysis and more creative
pursuits there are a few very
specialized there are very few
specialized domains where humans still
outperform computers and this means that
wherever possible human collective
should prefer to shift decision-making
away from humans and towards machines
which of course we can expect to greatly
enhance the progressive disempowerment
of humans machine learning algorithms
are brilliant that they are usually very
specialized they're generally not
endowed with moral intuitions and more
importantly they don't look at things in
the context of broad human values they
don't ask themselves how will my
decision affect humanity generally given
everything that I can possibly know
about the world this is a phenomenon
sometimes referred to as artificial
stupidity when people talk about
artificial intelligence as a threat to
humanity they usually dismissed because
well why wouldn't I I want to hurt us I
think if we consider collectives as
beings with semi-independent interests
from ours that evolve in their own right
we can understand the likely motivations
of a is much more explicitly at least
the kind of a is that we are going to
create as a species and whilst these
motives are not intrinsically hostile to
humanity they're also not inherently
friendly their ultimate motive is to
accrue power and the ways in which we
let them do this a crucial to how we
should expect them to evolve so to sum
up all of this I've argued that there's
a meaningful analogy between evolving
collective entities in nature and
collective human organizations and I've
suggested that this results in some
context concerning trends especially in
terms of progressive disempowerment of
human individuals
as the collective entities that we've
created this is primarily a verbal
argument as yet it's based on some
mathematical models from evolutionary
biology whose assumptions and
conclusions don't necessarily extend to
human collectives but if it is collected
correct to any degree then perhaps it's
time we stopped fighting about whether
government or corporations are more evil
except that they both naturally opposed
naturally evolved to at times oppose
human interests and start looking for
ways to make them evolve into something
better for humans thank you so question
this is very much a tangent but I was
intrigued by your dog cancer that had
lived mine a thousand years or something
eleven thousand years yeah how would
this one quantify perhaps one know that
this is the same workers in the same
cells presumably yes it's a cell lineage
from the original dog and then and they
can measure that by changes in neutral
DNA so DNA that doesn't actually code
for anything but evolves with a sort of
semi regular pace rate at which cells
and does YouTube yeah yeah so we're a
pack of wolves fit in on the scale um I
think that depends on who you ask so
wolves het wolves generally have a
dominant pair a dominant mating pair and
that's the only one that these are the
only wolves that breed was in a pack and
then you have armed a group of younger
individuals who are not ready to
establish their own pack and they
contribute to hunting and um sometimes
occasionally they will manage to breed a
bit
um but generally it's only the
monogamous dominant pair that will braid
so yeah listen would probably I guess
say that they're a little bit on the
road to your sociality and most people
would say no that's just kin selection
does that make sense yep so I'm bringing
out the analogy on fire you know I can
do great harmony good so when you think
about human collectors are you thinking
that it's dangerous to have larger
supposing bodies like you then and so on
me is it better not to do it because the
the change with a dangerous terrain
that's that's a really interesting
question and I honestly don't know I I
wouldn't automatically say that large
collectives are a bad thing I think we
really don't know much about how
collectives evolve because we don't
think of organizations as evolving in in
any independent sense and everything
we've achieved as a species has come
about because of our ability to form
collectives as well so there's there's
great power and great danger as you say
like fire so if you think about the
emergence of the Internet to smoke the
ends of this buildings over the Internet
I mean the internet definite the basis
for potentially creating a superorganism
are a global scale human collective yes
you about things we can do to make sure
its people sending um I have some some
ideas I don't know that I would go so
far as to say I have a viewpoint because
I think this is something that needs a
lot of research it seems to me that um
if we can arm the destabilize the
relationship networks that collectives
establish among themselves that might
that might help because political
lobbying by collectives obviously
provides them with a lot of extra clout
in terms of the fate of humanity arm I
think there's potential for
organizations for four people within
organizations to work to restructure
them to increase transparency and arm
change the goals of the organizations to
align better with human interests so are
a a search engine say has an intrinsic
interest that to some extent aligns with
human human well-being everyone wants
better search and they want their search
to be objective but there are of course
potential situations where that ceases
to be true so um the more you can
channel the collective interest of your
organization away from that those sorts
of moral dilemmas the better I guess one
of your slides seem to be saying the
power inherently corrupts people or
power greens hypocrisy or power has a
bad effect on the people too powerful um
there's only there are some people of
power remain altruistic more so than
others to what extent can you separate
that the power is causing something
versus the the latent hypocrite is
looking for a way to exploit his power
or somebody's already corrupted is
trying to look for a way to take
advantage of the situation there have
been a couple of studies that tried to
look at that
so usually the way they do this is they
prime people to feel powerful by by
presenting them with scenarios and then
and then give them some sort of moral
dilemma in in some studies though that I
think there was one study that suggested
that in fact empowering people didn't
change their initial moral
predisposition um but I think later on
the same researchers went back and did a
more long-term study and they found that
actually over time people became corrupt
even if they weren't initially so it
digitally just took longer but I could
be misrepresenting the literature would
need to check that so you mentioned
cheating several times and there's been
a lot of work recently with fMRI to find
regions in the brain has anybody found
the region associated with cheating not
that I'm aware of it looks worse no um I
don't know I I don't know about that
though they were argument there have
been arguments since the 1990s that we
have some sort of dedicated brain
circuitry for cheetah detection but I'm
not aware of any neurological evidence
that supports that
my question was how did you build this
list what did you resource and what sort
of in your thinking and also noticing
that it anyways seems to mirror some of
the things that are going on with whole
offices and other ways of creating flat
organizations etc so there's a mirror
this out in society so how did you
produce this III can't say I have any
formal process for that down it's it's
I'd as a list of ideas but that occurred
to me when I was but when I fear I mean
I've been trying to think about possible
solutions to this that's also i'm sure
i'm just getting it out of popular
culture and yes oh thank you absol
intrigued by the cheating brothers power
and corruption and democracy thing um
presumably an organism would have to
have a certain level of understanding
the world who for its behavior can be
changed in one direction or another i
think of insects for instance being hard
wired with a in a bee colony does the
Queen try to exploit her power in the
situation or do you have to have some
self-awareness and ability to analyze
the world to figure out your as a
situation can take advantage of you
don't need self-awareness so in quite a
lot of species the Queen will manipulate
that the sex ratio of her offspring for
instance and this is this may or may not
be in the interests of the of the
workers they will try to manipulate it
back and you get this power dynamic the
the way it works is that the Queen will
secrete pheromones and and use chemical
signaling 20 to influence the behavior
of other individuals and then the
workers will do will do the same thing
in reverse so it's a self-organizing
process it doesn't need to be conscious
at all I know
education their difference there's Nick
they are in something you can call group
draw some different to different other
groups so I don't know whose who is
cheated me you saying the question their
workers are cheap okay everybody is
trying to cheat the collective entity I
guess and I suppose yeah well so we can
think of the interests of the hive the
interest of the Queen and the interests
of the workers so if you assume that the
goal of the nest is to be cooperative
well from the point of view of the of
the super organism argument to the
extent that they represent a single
individual they should be trying to
cooperate to reproduce as a as a whole
nest but they're not a single super
organism there's three super organisms
ah hey missed a few social insects is is
a single superorganism it's a lot it's a
lot of different organisms but it's a
single superorganism involves problems
this because won't happen to be the
biggest why is it the only one whose
goal should be pushed well that's kind
of the the question of this whole talk I
mean should should should we be
submitting to the interests of our
collectives because they're bigger than
us eh it's from the point of view of
individual ants or bees it's the same
dilemma they just have a stronger
interest in supporting the collective
these bees where the queen is trying to
play things for her own benefit is that
Universal on bees or feasible particular
breed or Evelyn be Queen somebody
there's a lot of variation in social
systems between different species honey
bees for instance a pretty much
consistent co-operators they said they
don't they don't really cheap much
whereas in in some species of ants the
workers will get good all sorts of
manipulations to try to change things in
their own interests I guess what I'm
thinking is getting back to the question
of to what extent is this be a here
learned required overtime versus hard
wired with into organism know if if
these are certain species if some hives
are benevolent others are manipulative
that would suggest I don't know what the
nanos I'm just intrigued by the idea
within species usually that the behavior
will be will be consistent you won't see
much difference between individual nests
so that implies maybe that the queen is
coming corrupted with power or maybe the
queen is hardwired to try to stress on
aspect of the dynamics that comes to
play any other genders mature yeah it's
it's all pretty much hardwired they can
have some response to environmental cues
where they change their behavior pattern
but but they're not really capable of
thinking about their situation and
saying hey I could advantage myself do I
doing this evidence of punishment of
cheaters within the social insects and
yes so there are these amps for instance
where occasionally a worker will develop
ovaries which means she's going to lay
eggs and when the when the other ants
see this cheating I grant you a few more
flirting ah sure King oh it isn't really
in their interest to shirk generally I
think such punishment but um yes wow
that's that's the question yeah but if
the grasshopper has a violin that could
make everybody happy and be good for the
community and what about those
dandelions they're really asexual
reproduction at genetic copies age level
no no pollen exchange in order to create
the the following students they kind of
use their own pollens or they're making
seeds but the seeds are genetically
identical to the parent so the Saline
happens to be good that day they get
poem mixed up from your labor I i I'm
not sure how that works actually I think
that they're also capable of sexual
reproduction sometimes but most of the
time they just finding themselves and
the bees cooperate in order to do who
I'm going to Palm this talent who well
yeah actually that's that's kind of what
happens with a lot of insect plant
relationships there'll be specialization
with different hosts and different kinds
of flowers and new species arising
because of that yes I want to point out
that i think someone corruption is a
loaded term hmm because I come from the
Chinese culture and when the one dynasty
would be taken over by the next one they
called it the passing of the Mandate of
Heaven the what was the attack and the
revolution then became the received
wisdom until it lost its thing and so
that I feel that it's kind of its
survival of the species that we don't
actually always continue that we need
what you're calling corruption or
seeking advantage on an individual level
in order to renew and as well it's right
by just calling into question that the
word corruption really buys into the
status flow yes it does yeah the this
question of how much we should be
policing things versus fostering
diversity I think is really um complex
there were there was this so I wrote an
article talking about this policing
issue for her magazine a while ago and
what one of the issues in it was you
know could we create universal policing
in humans it
and if we did what would happen what
would happen to creativity and and talk
to our collective evolution would it be
a good thing or a bad thing and a lot of
people were very upset by this just last
week there was this app people that came
out I'm not sure exactly out yet but
they're the idea is that you write you
review other people and that's I think
everyone immediately saw that that would
be an absolutely horrible thing to do
yeah as we do it happen to the Wikipedia
today and then you have police and
levels of police hmm now that is killed
corruption it that we said it's not
perhaps a lot about the different
beehives are there different levels of
what you call cheating those are those
super organisms at some point the Queen
cheating gave them some advantage over
some other hide the didn't queen sheet
and in some other situation the worker
cheating evidence of advantage so they
ended so we're seeing the result of the
success of what chicken and the
different species or at different
situations they went through so cheating
helps can rehearse this example of
cheating of the United States of America
the actual American Revolution yeah um
well would you elaborate on that so we
thought it was corrupt not to pay taxes
and direct to the Boston Tea Party and
so on and to bring out this new idea
that one man one vote and that people
should have be able to have town
councils and decide how the community
could work that was not possible in
Europe or in Asia it was only possible
because of the open territory and the
richness of the land that allowed enough
people to come
organize the it was touch and go whether
the 13 colonies would agree to this but
to me in the way you use the term
corruption be a mirror that the founding
of the American Republic was that the
greatest example of corruption I think
that's a really good point yeah and and
you can also sort of see the emergence
of competing coalition's in that because
you can't have a revolution by yourself
you have you have to form your own
collective and fight fight for what you
value but the meme of the American
Constitution has been the cottage and
modified anuja around the matter you
haven't lose right see the words become
important authors authors are spreaders
of memes very important yeah so you
discussed a little bit about machine
learning agents that are good at some
very specific task and implied that if
they were to self organizing this could
be very poor for human interests and
that seems to make sense but I think
that we are lacking the whole genetic
algorithm to get them to globally
optimized with each other and if we
consider that we don't have that how
might such a system work it's like you
have oceans 11 and you're trying to pull
a heist on humanity but there's no
George cool so like what I didn't see
any ideas you have any ideas about how
we might expect a pseudo biological
system or mechanical system to develop
deceit cheating and such and organized
into a collective um so I'm not I'm not
really suggesting that any particular AI
is going to take on this sort of
sentient demonic in individualism I
think what what's much more likely
that you have an algorithm that's just
doing what algorithms do every day in
our lives optimizing some some function
it is not something to do with its share
price something to do with manipulating
in an economic situation and its is
completely ignorant of the human
consequences of its actions or of how
that will play out globally sorry yes
exactly
you